hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about hbo's lovecraft country
season 1 episode 4. we genre hop again
this time we're in the realm of
adventure and a lot of stuff goes down
from chicago to boston
and beyond christina is still lurking
around hippolyta is still thinking she's
being kept in the dark about what really
happened to her husband
tick letty and montrose set off on an
adventure to try to get a hold of
titus's pages from the book of names
in an effort to even the score in their
struggle with the order of the ancient
dawn
before we dive in this is your spoiler
warning i'm gonna talk about everything
that happened in the first four episodes
of lovecraft country
this will include some corresponding
details from the book it was based on
up to where we're at in the story and at
the end i'll talk about some theories
book changes and speculation from that
but i'll give you another warning before
i go there
now let's talk about episode 4 a history
of violence
which was written by misha greene and
wes taylor and directed by victoria
mahoney
the episode opens with montrose who
appears to be trying to drink his way
through his mourning over the loss of
his brother feeling bad about george's
death is at least
one thing he has going on but as the
episode develops you get the idea that
there's more
in voiceover we hear george say you
might be all tick has
left just as we find out that he has the
book of bylaws and precepts of the order
of the ancient dawn he throws it in a
trash can and burns it
we did get a look inside though and
later we'll see what we've read
help get them out of a jam as mentioned
christina braithwight is still staying
in chicago she pays a visit to letty at
the winthrop house
apparently the mark on the door in
goat's blood is enough to keep her out
letty figures out that the money for the
house came from her but christina
assures her
all she wants is hiram's orry the orori
is a model of a solar system
and we saw hippolyta come across it in
episode 3.
it's interesting since that room had
been locked and it's almost like she was
called to it
in this episode we see she has it at the
office she removed it from the winthrop
house at some point during the
housewarming party
we hear her talking on the phone to her
father asking him about it asking about
a solar system with two sons
one of the men in the office tells her
that he thinks she'll figure out how to
make it work
saying every lock thing has its key
after her conversation with letty
christina gets picked up by some cops
and taken to meet with captain lancaster
the cop that gave letty the rough ride
in episode 3.
there's tension between them and we get
the idea that he has a history with her
family
there's also a weird indication that he
is a prisoner locked up inside a closet
or something like that in his office
christina tells him that she's in
chicago looking for hiram
epstein's orry and adds the question
that is the key to unlocking his time
machine
isn't it who the captain is and what he
means by his lodge is still a mystery
based just on this conversation he seems
to not be a member of the order of the
ancient
dawn given his connection to the
winthrop house and epstein it would make
sense that they have their own group
that evolved alongside it
after that christina heads home to the
house she's staying at in chicago in a
weird sequence
she goes in and william comes right back
out to beat up the cops that had been
following her
it's weird because of the way it's shot
and i think this is a pretty good
indication that confirms a popular
theory
i'll come back to that at the end
ruby goes into martial fields where
she's been trying to get a job working
at the counter
she sees there's a black woman working
there now and is disappointed because
she knows she missed her chance
this adds to her resentment that's been
building up against her sister
or should i say her half-sister letty
william approaches ruby
telling her that he can change her life
she's skeptical but she listens to him
because he's buying her drinks
after some back and forth he takes her
home to the house where we saw christina
arrive at earlier
they hook up in a pretty hot scene on
the stairs and we see that he has a
giant
brand on his chest at the library tick's
been researching titus
after her meeting with christina letty
goes looking for him and she finds him
there he tells letty that christina has
a spell that protects her from harm
and that she used tic to take out her
father he's there because he wants to
find titus's pages
and in the process he figures out
montrose has already done the same
research
when he looks at the library cards
inside each book
he goes looking for him and he finds
montrose and letty together
his father doesn't want to help them at
first after letty prods him some
he tells her he thinks he knows where
the pages are hidden in boston
during the conversation he also lets it
slip that he knows that there are 34
lodges and this is something that the
others take note of
they do all go to boston and they bring
hippolyta diana
and this guy tree along they make it to
the museum
hippolyta and diana go off to check out
the astronomy exhibit while the others
go to look for titus's bolt
we learn more about hippolyta's interest
in astronomy and how she got beat out
naming the herod's chariot comet when
she was a girl
in the middle of an exchange tree makes
a comment about montrose getting close
with sammy from the bar
tick doesn't pay much attention to it
because he's got other things on his
mind
but this and the otherwise out of place
scene with sammy getting a [ __ ] from
a young man outside the bar starts to
make you wonder
i actually think there's a pretty good
chance that montrose is closeted but
we'll have to see where they go with
that this isn't something that's from
the book necessarily
after looking around tick realizes that
titus's vault is under the statue
and montrose tells him the security
guard will help them get
in after hours when they come back they
find the entrance to an underground
area tick tries to go down by himself
but they all end up down there
when letty grabs the map throws it down
goes down the rope she just takes charge
basically
after some arguing they pick one of the
three tunnels and head off looking for
the pages
tick thinks they should have thought
about things more and he notices that
the lantern's missing from one of the
other tunnels
after walking for 20 minutes they find a
plank over this giant chasm
they decide to cross it and they run
into booby trap when letty passes the
first one
a swinging blade the plank starts to
disappear
after a genuinely funny exchange they
make it to the door on the other side
just in time montrose remembers what he
read in the book and is able to figure
out the combination
when they get inside we see that the
tide is starting to rise on them
up to their chest and water tick
confronts mantras about how he knows so
much about the order
he tells them about reading the book and
that when he was done he burn it
he says he's trying to close pandora's
box and protect his family and i do
think this is why montrose is doing the
things he's doing
but tick and letty are probably right
that they would be better off knowing
how to fight back against christina
letty notices one of her dead neighbors
floating in the water and then they find
the elevator from her house is connected
magically to where they are
tick tries to send them away but let he
insists on staying
ticking mantras have a father and son
moment briefly
and then they find a lock to the bolt in
the wall there's an
arm from the last person that tried to
open it left behind in the lock
since tick has titus's blood he's able
to unlock it after it gives him a flesh
wound
inside the hatch they find mummified
remains a la
chester copper pot and the goonies they
find the pages from the book of names
but when they try to take them
the mummy holding them reanimates as it
comes back to life we see that it's
multi-gendered both male and female they
were translating for titus until they
realized what kind of man he was
this led them to being imprisoned in the
balt they don't really blame
tick for what happened but they don't
want to help him either because they
don't know a spirit
when montrose grabs the pages the water
rushes
in and they have to escape bringing the
two spirit with them
montrose tries to leave the pages behind
when they go into the elevator
but letty sees them floating so she
swims out and grabs them and is able to
get back in time
this impresses take and he uses the
moment to kiss her passionately
just before the two spirit lets out this
crazy scream
in the car hippolyta and diana are
driving back
and they're confused about how the
others were able to return to chicago
when she notices diana is looking at
george's atlas
she decides to go to devon county and or
artem to look for answers about his
death
we find out the two spirit is under a
spell to be a siren so they can't speak
they're all still in the winter of house
together montrose tells his son that
he's proud of him
and they have a real moment but then
after he leaves
montrose kills the siren with a slash of
the throat and the episode ends there
so a big adventure for the gang and it
was successful and they have the pages
for the book of names now
montrose is doing his best to be a
frustrating character
and his getting slashy at the end is
going to be hard to explain to the
others
christina mentioning time travel in
relation to epstein is an interesting
development
as is ruby and william hooking up since
george never dies in the book
it's unclear what hippolyta is gonna
find when she goes looking into his
death
this episode had some really fun parts
to it but i'm still not a big fan of the
pacing
like it seemed like everything at night
in the museum happened so fast that you
really kind of miss out on some of the
details
that's pretty much what happened so now
i'm going to get into some theories and
then talk about some stuff that they
changed from the book if you want to
avoid that now is your chance to leave
the one big question i had when they
gender swapped caleb from the book
into christina on the show was how they
were gonna handle ruby's storyline
it seemed like it was essential for ruby
to hook up with the brace white
after episode two aired the theory came
out that christina and william are the
same person
and now i think that's almost definitely
the case
we've never seen them on screen together
and christina is obviously versed in
using spells
it makes sense that william would be
useful to her in relation to spying on
the order since women aren't allowed
anywhere near the meetings
and it also solves the problem with ruby
william was basically introduced as
hired help but if he's going to take the
role of giving ruby the potion
that certainly indicates that he's more
involved in the family business
if not just a different version of
christina who can swap genders
also the brand he has seems similar to
caleb's mark in the book
and this could be a hint that they are
the same person if the brand is the
thing that keeps christina safe from
harm
considering they rerouted everything to
put them in boston so that hippolyta
would be close to devon county
makes me think that george will
definitely be returning in one way or
another
i guess there's a chance that they were
just trying to give hippolyta and diana
more to do early in the story but i
still can't imagine that we've seen the
last of george
it's curious because the story is that
george was killed by a cop and then she
implied that she understood
that in revenge that they killed the cop
so it'll be interesting to see if she
has a face to face with him when she
gets to wherever she's going
i think with that i'll leave it right
there let me know in the comments what
you thought about episode 4 and what
you're hoping to see in the next one
please like the video if you enjoyed it
and subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon